Shure:  没有，没有，没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  我靠这都是能播的吗
Shure: Oh man, can this even be broadcasted?
Shure的女友:所以
Shure's GF: So
Shure:  所以什么
Shure: So what?
Shure的女友: 所以用牙起个瓶子而已
Shure: So you just used your teeth to open a bottle.
Shure的女友: 就是就是就是
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友: 你你你起不开
Shure: You, you, you couldn't open it.
Shure的女友: 然后然后你说哇好牛
Shure: And then you said, wow, that's awesome.
Shure的女友: 我能理解
Shure: I can understand.
Shure的女友: 那为什么要跟我说
Shure: But why tell me that?
Shure的女友: 我说哦这个
Shure: I said, oh, this...
Shure的女友: 我爸我妈看到之后也得说一句卧槽
Shure: If my parents saw it, they would say "damn".
Shure的女友: 牛为什么呀
Shure: Why is that impressive?
Shure的女友: 啊大家都不会吗
Shure: Doesn't everyone know how to do it?
Shure:  我爸应该会
Shure: My dad probably knows how.
Shure的女友：嗯
Shure: Mm.
Shure:  但我妈肯定觉得这姑娘不简单
Shure: But my mom would definitely think that girl is something special.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 什么呀
Shure: What?
Shure的女友: 就是有的时候
Shure: Sometimes...
Shure的女友: 没有瓶起子的时候是这样的
Shure: When there's no bottle opener, we do this.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure的女友: 我那个
Shure: My...
Shure的女友: 我那个瓶起子不是连上我家钥匙吗
Shure: My bottle opener is attached to my house keys, right?
Shure的女友: 我好像给拉家里了
Shure: I think I left it at home.
Shure的女友: 那个门禁的那个那个那个FC那个钥匙
Shure: That door access key, the FC one.
Shure的女友: 然后我好像都给拉家里了
Shure: I think I left it at home.
Shure的女友: 因为我觉得有指纹我不需要那个东西
Shure: Because I thought with fingerprints, I didn't need it.
Shure的女友: 所以给扔那了
Shure: So I left it there.
Shure:  求起子
Shure: Asking for a bottle opener.
Shure的女友: 吃什么呀
Shure: What are you eating?
Shure:  你这两天吃面了吗
Shure: Have you had noodles in the past two days?
Shure:  我这两天不是都是在跟你一块吃的吗
Shure: Haven't I been eating with you these past two days?
Shure:  昨天你是跟谁吃的
Shure: Who did you eat with yesterday?
Shure的女友: 哎哎哎哎呀哎呀
Shure: Eh, eh, eh, oh, oh.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:没吃
Shure: Didn't eat.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 好好好那说漏嘴就说漏嘴呗
Shure: Okay, okay, if you misspoke, you misspoke.
Shure:  咱们可以解释一下吗
Shure: Can we explain?
Shure的女友: 因为我真想不起来了
Shure: Because I really can't remember.
Shure:  真想不起来跟谁吃了
Shure: You really can't remember who you ate with?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  是.
Shure: Yes.
Shure的女友:你昨天吃的啥呀
Sister: What did you eat yesterday?
Shure:  昨天你昨天
Shure: Yesterday, you, yesterday...
Shure:  哎你昨天一天都没好好吃饭
Shure: Hey, you didn't eat properly all day yesterday.
Shure:  早上没吃中午去那边吃了个三明治
Shure: You skipped breakfast, had a sandwich for lunch over there,
Shure:  然后晚上回来也没吃
Shure: and then didn't eat anything when you got back in the evening.
Shure:  然后晚上开始找你就饿了
Shure: And then you started looking for me because you were hungry.
Shure的女友:哦
Sister: Oh.
Shure:  你看看
Shure: See?
Shure的女友：就是没吃
Sister: So, you didn't eat.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Sister: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 那就是没吃
Sister: So, you didn't eat.
Shure的女友: 哦我昨天
Sister: Oh, yesterday...
Shure的女友: 哦对我昨天下午去拉菲去了
Sister: Oh right, I went to Raffy in the afternoon.
Shure的女友: 嗯然后晚上
Sister: Yeah, and then in the evening...
Shure的女友: 晚上回来之后干嘛了
Sister: What did I do after I got back in the evening?
Shure:  晚上回那个我在床上喝了
Shure: In the evening, I was drinking on the bed.
Shure:  喝了点酒然后开始翻梦话合集
Shure: Had some drinks and started watching a compilation of sleep-talking.
Shure的女友: 我晚上十点多钟回来
Sister: I got back around 10 PM.
Shure的女友: 我拿了瓶酒
Sister: I grabbed a bottle of wine.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友: 然后
Sister: And then...
Shure的女友: 然后从从教室回来就11点多
Sister: And then, I got back from the classroom around 11 PM.
Shure的女友: 然后11点半准备睡觉的时候
Sister: And then at 11:30, when I was getting ready to sleep,
Shure的女友: 忙完开始发消息
Sister: I started sending messages after I was done.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure的女友:那我昨天晚上就没吃
Sister: So, I didn't eat anything last night.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure的女友:对
Sister: Yeah.
Shure的女友: 然后那个
Sister: And then...
Shure: 你说我不在你都不好好吃饭
Shure: You know, when I'm not around, you don't eat properly.
Shure的女友: 好好吃嘛
Sister: I eat well.
Shure:  南子你没我怎么活呀
Shure: How can you live without me, Nanzi?
Shure:  南子哈哈哈
Shure: Nanzi, hahaha.
Shure的女友: 我昨天一天的那个碳水摄入
Sister: My carb intake for the whole day yesterday was definitely enough.
Shure的女友: 肯定是够的
Sister: Because of the alcohol.
Shure的女友: 因为喝酒
Sister: Because I drank.
Shure:  什么碳水这是
Shure: What carbs are you talking about?
Shure的女友: 哎我今天
Sister: Hey, today...
Shure的女友: 你知道我今天
Sister: You know, today...
Shure: 看什么吗
Shure: Watching something?
Shure的女友: 今天刷小红书就刷到一条
Shure's GF: Today, I was scrolling through Xiaohongshu and saw a post.
Shure的女友: 说那个健身夜夜段用伏特加
Shure's GF: It said that some fitness enthusiast was using vodka for their night routine.
Shure的女友: 给我乐坏了
Shure's GF: It cracked me up.
Shure的女友: 然后在记录他每天就是夜段第几天
Shure's GF: Then he was recording his progress every night, like what day it was.
Shure的女友: 第几天然后他的体重变化
Shure's GF: What day it was and how his weight was changing.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  明天早上答完辩还要回去
Shure: After my defense tomorrow morning, I need to go back.
Shure:  不饿
Shure: Not hungry.
Shure的女友:我周五去威海
Shure's GF: I'm going to Weihai on Friday.
Shure的女友: 周日回来
Shure's GF: Coming back on Sunday.
Shure的女友: 又是周末哦
Shure's GF: Another weekend, huh.
Shure:  噢你周日还不在北京是吧
Shure: Oh, so you won’t be in Beijing on Sunday, right?
Shure的女友: 怎么了怎么了怎么了
Shure's GF: What's up, what's up, what's up?
Shure:  啊没事
Shure: Ah, nothing.
Shure的女友：怎么了
Shure's GF: What's up?
Shure:  问题不大
Shure: It's no big deal.
Shure的女友: 我应该周日下午回
Shure's GF: I should be back by Sunday afternoon.
Shure的女友: 怎么了
Shure's GF: What's up?
Shure:  行那你下午直接来通州吧
Shure: Alright, then just come to Tongzhou in the afternoon.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Shure的女友: 干嘛
Shure's GF: What for?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure的女友: 干嘛
Shure's GF: What for?
Shure:  来参加
Shure: Come join the...
Shure:  after party
Shure: After party.
Shure:  没什么就是最后一天要有一个
Shure: Nothing, it's just that on the last day, there’s going to be a...
Shure:  就是活动吧
Shure: You know, an event.
Shure:  然后邀请就是自己的亲朋好友
Shure: And we're inviting friends and family.
Shure:  亲朋好友齐聚一堂
Shure: Friends and family gathering together.
Shure的女友: 你们哪天啊
Shure's GF: What day is it?
Shure:  21号 这周日
Shure: The 21st, this Sunday.
Shure的女友: 几点啊
Shure's GF: What time?
Shure: 3点
Shure: 3 PM.
Shure:  你几点了
Shure: What time do you have?
Shure的女友: 你手机我看一眼
Shure's GF: Let me see your phone.
Shure的女友: 我忘记了
Shure's GF: I forgot.
Shure:  你手机在我这吗
Shure: Is your phone with me?
Shure的女友: 你不提前跟我说
Shure's GF: You didn't tell me earlier.
Shure:  我没没事没事
Shure: I didn't, it's fine, it's fine.
Shure:  你要回不来就OK
Shure: It's fine if you can't come back.
Shure:  我叫畅宝来
Shure: I'll call Changbao.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  那正好缺个调酒师
Shure: We just need a bartender.
Shure的女友：那太好了。
Shure's GF: That’s great.
Shure:  你看看你看看你看看你看看你看看
Shure: Look, look, look, look, look.
Shure的女友：我也不用担心啦
Shure's GF: Now I don't have to worry anymore.
Shure的女友：看什么？
Shure's GF: Look at what?
Shure:  看看这几点了
Shure: Look at the time.
Shure:  栗子栗子
Shure: Chestnuts, chestnuts.
Shure:  你手为什么出汗
Shure: Why are your hands sweating?
Shure:  7点呢嗯
Shure: It's 7 o'clock, hmm.
Shure:  还是4点那个时候回来的啊
Shure: Are you coming back at 4 o'clock?
Shure:  7点
Shure: 7 o'clock.
Shure:  那算了那完蛋了
Shure: Never mind, we're done for.
Shure的女友: 然后他5个多小时的高铁呢
Shure's GF: Then there's a 5-hour high-speed train ride.
Shure: 也是
Shure: Right.
Shure:  嗯找找畅宝吧
Shure: Hmm, let's find Changbao.
Shure:  我们的guest就变成了我们的调酒师
Shure: Our guest will become our bartender.
Shure的女友: 嗯真好
Shure's GF: Hmm, that's nice.
Shure: 挺好
Shure: Very nice.
Shure的女友: 不关我事了
Shure's GF: It's not my problem anymore.
Shure:  噢你那个马歇尔还在吗
Shure: Oh, is your Marshall still there?
Shure的女友：我背会儿家了
Shure's GF: I brought it home.
Shure:  拿拿家去了
Shure: Took it home?
Shure:  是吗好的
Shure: Really? Okay.
Shure的女友: 那我毕业了我还把它放学校干嘛
Shure's GF: Why would I leave it at school after graduating?
Shure的女友: 我本来以为没有什么需要用到的地方
Shure's GF: I thought I wouldn’t need it anywhere else.
Shure的女友: 毕竟我跟我舍友也不太熟
Shure's GF: After all, I wasn't very close with my roommates.
Shure的女友: 呵呵
Shure's GF: Hehe.
Shure: 不能在室内大放音乐是吗
Shure: You can't play loud music indoors, right?
Shure的女友：嗯对
Shure's GF: Yeah, right.
Shure:  你可以带他们蹦迪
Shure: You could take them to a club.
Shure:  给他们放浴室DJ版
Shure: Play the DJ version in the bathroom.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  你给他们说快
Shure: Tell them quickly.
Shure:  我们带你们听摇滚
Shure: We'll take you to listen to rock.
Shure的女友: 哎呦你知道我
Shure's GF: Oh, you know,
Shure的女友: 本来我订票的时候
Shure's GF: When I was booking tickets,
Shure的女友: 我想是我朋友周末他下班有空吗
Shure's GF: I was wondering if my friend would be free after work on the weekend.
Shure的女友: 结果就是因为我有点太说走就走了
Nina: So the result is that I was a bit too impulsive.
Shure的女友: 然后他早就约好了
Nina: And then he had already made plans.
Shure的女友: 他这周末有朋友要过来
Nina: He has friends coming over this weekend.
Shure的女友: 我还不认识我就不太想去
Nina: I don't know them, so I don't really want to go.
Shure的女友: 然后搞得我这次去威威海
Nina: So this time when I go to Weiwei Sea,
Shure的女友: 我可能就是跟栗子他们玩一圈
Nina: I might just hang out with Lizi and the gang.
Shure:  挺好的看看海
Shure: That's nice, you can see the sea.
Shure:  又有海了
Shure: There’s the sea again.
Shure:  怎么不跟我邮了
Shure: Why didn’t you mail me?
Shure:  别别别别你没事没事
Shure: No, no, no, you’re fine, you’re fine.
Shure的女友: 嗯你看最早的话他也就是下午下午
Nina: Hmm, you see, the earliest would be in the afternoon.
Shure的女友: 中午到下午到
Nina: From noon to afternoon.
Shure:  没事没事
Shure: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure:  别没必要没必要
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure的女友: 没有就是跟你说一下我真的回不来
Nina: No, I’m just letting you know that I really can’t come back.
Shure的女友: 所以你不要想
Nina: So don’t think about it.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Nina: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 没别的意思就是给自己找一下借口
Nina: I don’t mean anything, just giving myself an excuse.
Shure:  OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure:  我们要等红灯嗯
Shure: We have to wait for the red light, hmm.
Shure:  额额
Shure: Uh, uh.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  兄弟你好香
Shure: Bro, you smell so nice.
Shure的女友: 你好变态
Nina: You’re such a perv.
Shure: 嘿嘿
Shure: Hehe.
Shure:  怎么了怎么了
Shure: What’s up, what’s up?
Shure的女友: 你干嘛
Nina: What are you doing?
Shure:  咦咦这谁啊
Shure: Ew, ew, who’s that?
Shure的女友：这谁啊
Nina: Who’s that?
Shure:  谁
Shure: Who?
Shure的女友: 看不懂翻译一下
Nina: Can’t understand, translate it.
Shure: 不知呀
Shure: No idea.
Shure:  走
Shure: Let’s go.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Shure:  差点撞到人哎
Shure: Almost hit someone, hey.
Shure的女友: 他差点撞到我
Nina: He almost hit me.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure的女友: 真过分
Nina: So rude.
Shure: 他右拐不让直行他全责
Shure: He turned right without yielding, it's totally his fault.
Shure:  吃什么吃什么
Shure: What should we eat?
Shure: 那吃面吧
Shure: Let's have noodles.
Shure的女友：好
Sister: Okay.
Shure: 金楠士
Shure: Jin Nanshi.
Shure的女友：好啊
Sister: Sure.
Shure:  又馋那个
Shure: Craving that again.
Shure:  小炒肉面
Shure: Stir-fried pork noodles.
Shure:  突突突突
Shure: Tutu tutu.
Shure的女友: 哎呀绕圈推我一下
Sister: Oh, can you push me around?
Shure:  终于知道你这个什么分离焦虑哪来的
Shure: I finally know where your separation anxiety comes from.
Shure:  确实没人找你了
Shure: No one really contacts you.
Shure的女友: 什么叫确实没人找我啊
Sister: What do you mean no one contacts me?
Shure的女友: 我很忙的好吗
Sister: I'm really busy, okay?
Shure:  吵你吵你什么找你
Shure: Who's bothering you, who's contacting you?
Shure的女友: 显得我像什么社交废物
Sister: You're making me look like a social outcast.
Shure的女友: 没有朋友好吗
Sister: Like I have no friends, okay?
Shure:  没有我我怎么会这么说你呢
Shure: Without me, why would I say that about you?
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure的女友:哎呀
Sister: Oh man.
Shure: 我从来不说你坏话
Shure: I never talk bad about you.
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Shure的女友:不行
Sister: No way.
Shure的女友: 就是有点太吵了
Sister: It's just a bit too noisy.
Shure的女友:天天突然没没有讲话就
Sister: Suddenly there's no talking every day...
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Sister: Haha.
Shure: 好空旷啊
Shure: It's so empty.
Shure: 怎么世界安静了
Shure: Why is the world so quiet?
Shure: 我的世界没有声音了啊怎么办
Shure: My world has no sound, what should I do?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:我想给你比中指
Sister: I want to flip you off.
Shure的女友: 但是不想成为大家的素材啊
Sister: But I don't want to become material for everyone.
Shure:  没事你已经成为素材了
Shure: It's okay, you already are material.
Shure的女友: 啊
Sister: Ah.
Shure的女友: 哪里带路去
Sister: Where are you taking me?
Shure:  上次那家忘了吗
Shure: Remember that place last time?
Shure:  哎或者那个那个那个那个那个
Shure: Hey, or that, that, that...
Shure:  呃米
Shure: Uh rice.
Shure:  不是米线
Shure: Not rice noodles.
Shure:  去那叫什么来着
Shure: What was that place called?
Shure:  米粉我看那家米粉开没开
Shure: I wonder if that rice noodle place is open.
Shure:  如果开的话吃那家米粉
Shure: If it's open, we can eat at that rice noodle place.
Shure:  是的他开着呢
Shure: Yes, it's open.
Shure的女友: 是安徽菜还是北京菜
Sister: Is it Anhui cuisine or Beijing cuisine?
Shure:  哪个
Shure: Which one?
Shure:  星河小馆
Shure: Xinghe Bistro.
Shure的女友: 上面那个竖着的牌子
Sister: The vertical sign up there.
Shure:  徽京小镇
Shure: Huijing Town.
Shure:  他应该是京派安徽菜哈哈
Shure: It's probably Beijing-style Anhui cuisine, haha.
Shure的女友: 你晚上吃米粉是不是有点不消化
Sister: Eating rice noodles at night might be hard to digest.
Shure:  是吗我不知道啊
Shure: Really? I didn't know that.
Shure的女友: 粉这种东西是比面难消化的
Sister: Noodles are harder to digest than flour-based foods.
Shure:  嗯咦
Shure: Hmm, oh.
Shure的女友: 踩我一脚还
Sister: You stepped on my foot!
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure的女友: 对吃这个吃那个
Sister: You keep thinking about food.
Shure:  我其实无所谓
Shure: I actually don't mind.
Shure:  我也无所谓嗯哎呀
Shure: Yeah, I don't mind either. Oh well.
Shure的女友: 救命
Sister: Help!
Shure的女友:  吃什么
Sister: What should we eat?
Shure:  那吃面吧
Shure: Let's have noodles then.
Shure:  好吧你想粉吗
Shure: Alright, do you want rice noodles?
Shure的女友:我不饿
Sister: I'm not hungry.
Shure:  在yes or no里选的i don't饿
Shure: Choosing between yes or no, I say I'm not hungry.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Sister: Hahaha.
Shure:  后期打字幕都不知道怎么打的
Shure: The subtitles team will be so confused.
Shure:  啊先点菜
Shure: Ah, let's order first.
Shure:  来一个小炒肉拌面
Shure: Let's get a stir-fried pork noodle.
服务员: 还有其他的吗
Server: Anything else?
Shure:  来个凉菜吧
Shure: Let's get a cold dish.
Shure:  呃我看看要什么
Shure: Uh, let me see what we want.
Shure:  有
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  有那种什么口水鸡之类的东西吗
Shure: Do you have something like mouth-watering chicken?
Shure的女友: 我想要个凉皮啊
Sister: I want some cold noodles.
Shure:  来来份凉皮
Shure: Okay, one order of cold noodles.
Shure:  那就那就不要别的了
Shure: That should be enough, no more dishes.
服务员: 不要凉菜了
Server: No cold dish then?
Shure:  不要凉菜
Shure: No cold dish.
Shure:  行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure:  香
Shure: Smells good.
Shure的女友: 嗯栗子粥
Shure's GF: Hmm, chestnut porridge.
Shure的女友: 我去威海只有烤肉吃
Shure's GF: When I went to Weihai, there was only barbecue.
Shure的女友: 只有烤肉和酸菜鱼吃
Shure's GF: Only barbecue and pickled fish.
Shure:  栗子是地主之一
Shure: Chestnut is one of the landlords.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Shure的女友: 我如果周五晚上到的话
Shure's GF: If I arrive on Friday night,
Shure的女友: 周五晚上
Shure's GF: Friday night.
Shure的女友: 周五下午到周五晚上吃一顿饭
Shure's GF: Arrive Friday afternoon, have a meal on Friday night.
Shure的女友: 然后周日周六两顿
Shure's GF: Then two meals on Saturday and Sunday.
Shure的女友: 周日中午的话我应该就不找他们了
Shure's GF: On Sunday noon, I shouldn't bother them.
Shure的女友: 我应该就自己吃了三顿饭
Shure's GF: I should have eaten three meals by myself.
Shure的女友: 他什么都没有给我安排
Shure's GF: He didn't arrange anything for me.
Shure的女友: 就跟我说哎你想吃烤肉吗
Shure's GF: He just said, hey, do you want barbecue?
Shure的女友: 好的那我去吃烤肉
Shure's GF: Okay, I'll go for barbecue.
Shure的女友: 然后哎这个酸菜鱼好像最近那个
Shure's GF: Then, hey, this pickled fish, I recently got a coupon,
Shure的女友: 我刷到一个优惠券我们去吃吧
Shure's GF: Let's go eat.
Shure的女友: 我说好
Shure's GF: I said okay.
Shure的女友: 然后我说我说我能吃到你做的饭吗
Shure's GF: Then I said, can I eat the meal you cook?
Shure的女友: 栗子跟我说不能
Shure's GF: Chestnut said no.
Shure的女友: 栗子说栗子说在家都是小马做饭
Shure's GF: Chestnut said that at home, it's always Xiao Ma who cooks.
Shure的女友: 我说哦好的那我能吃到小马做的饭吗
Shure's GF: I said, oh, can I eat Xiao Ma's cooking then?
Shure:  小马说吃个嘚
Shure: Xiao Ma said, eat your heart out.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈哈
Shure's GF: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我看到了
Shure: I saw it.
Shure的女友: 哎呦
Shure's GF: Oh my.
Shure:  你就这样
Shure: Just like that.
Shure:  你还去呢
Shure: And you still go.
Shure:  跟我就直接啪
Shure: Just directly,
Shure:  啪把栗子删了
Shure: Delete Chestnut.
Shure:  现在删
Shure: Delete now.
Shure的女友:宝宝修硕让我把你删了
Shure's GF: Baby, Shure told me to delete you.
Shure:  什么东西
Shure: What?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure:  然后数据集里就是人类开始传瞎话
Shure: Then in the dataset, it’s like humans start spreading rumors.
Shure:  是怎么传的
Shure: How do they spread?
Shure:  为什么这个人开始
Shure: Why did this person start
Shure的女友:录音
Shure's GF: Recording.
Shure的女友: 是吧
Shure's GF: Right?
Shure的女友: 没有吧
Shure's GF: No?
Shure:  都有的
Shure: We've got everything.
Shure的女友：救命
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure的女友: 所以所以其实不穿外套真的不冷
Shure's GF: So actually, not wearing a coat isn't really cold.
Shure:  是的后悔的
Shure: Yeah, I regret it.
Shure的女友: 明天28度最高温
Shure's GF: Tomorrow, the highest temperature will be 28 degrees.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure的女友: 然后后天晚上开始降温
Shure's GF: And the day after, it will start to cool down at night.
Shure:  那个小院巨爽跟你讲
Shure: That little courtyard is awesome, I'm telling you.
Shure的女友: 怎么帅也要把它买下来送我吗
Shure's GF: So, are you going to buy it and give it to me, handsome?
Shure:  送你你会嫁给我吗
Shure: If I give it to you, will you marry me?
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Shure's GF: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 你看周三周四
Shure's GF: Look, Wednesday and Thursday.
Shure的女友: 然后周五的时候有一点哦
Shure's GF: And then on Friday, there's a little bit, oh.
Shure的女友: sorry这海边
Shure's GF: Sorry, the seaside.
Shure的女友: 通州通州通州通州
Shure's GF: Tongzhou, Tongzhou, Tongzhou, Tongzhou.
Shure的女友: 没有删了 ok
Shure's GF: Didn't delete it, okay.
Shure的女友: 呵呵
Shure's GF: Hehe.
Shure:  你怎么还特意加个通州是什么鬼
Shure: Why did you specifically add Tongzhou? What's that about?
Shure:  怎么
Shure: How come?
Shure:  难道是
Shure: Could it be...
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure的女友: 28度 28度
Shure's GF: 28 degrees, 28 degrees.
Shure的女友: 然后稍微降一点点温
Shure's GF: And then it will cool down a little bit.
Shure的女友: 然后这两天又开始暖和起来
Shure's GF: And then it will start warming up again over the next couple of days.
Shure的女友: 这不是为了方便去环球吗
Shure's GF: Isn't this just perfect for going to Universal?
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  我怎么感觉是谁住在通州区呢
Shure: Why do I feel like someone lives in Tongzhou?
Shure的女友: 当然是环球啊
Shure's GF: Of course, it's Universal.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  行吧一定不是哪个前辈住在通州区吧
Shure: Alright, it must not be some senior living in Tongzhou.
Shure的女友：当然不是啦
Shure's GF: Of course not.
Shure的女友: 所以
Shure's GF: So,
Shure的女友: 其实后面两天就完全不需要穿外套了
Shure's GF: Actually, you won't need a coat at all in the next two days.
Shure的女友: 然后周五周六需要穿一下周
Shure's GF: And then on Friday and Saturday, you'll need one a bit, but
Shure的女友: 日又还很热
Shure's GF: Sunday will be hot again.
Shure的女友: 然后但是威海特别冷
Shure's GF: But Weihai will be really cold.
Shure的女友: 我在纠结我过去要穿什么
Shure's GF: I'm debating what to wear when I go there.
Shure:  穿裙子
Shure: Wear a dress.
Shure:  12度我去
Shure: 12 degrees, oh my.
Shure的女友: 穿裙子啊
Shure's GF: Wear a dress, huh?
Shure的女友: 杀了我吧
Shure's GF: Kill me.
Shure:  呃
Shure: Uh...
Shure:  穿雨衣吧
Shure: Wear a raincoat.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友: 对我得带伞
Shure's GF: Yeah, I need to bring an umbrella.
Shure的女友: 哎呀我不太想去了
Shure's GF: Ugh, I don't really want to go.
Shure:  退票吧
Shure: Let's cancel the ticket.
Shure的女友: 退票现在退票有手续费了
Shure's GF: Canceling the ticket now has a fee.
Shure:  那我给你补
Shure: I'll cover it for you.
Shure的女友：不用补
Shure's GF: No need to cover it.
Shure:  你看栗子都不回你了
Shure: Look, even Lizi isn't replying to you.
Shure:  直接删了吧
Shure: Just delete him.
Shure的女友: 他说他说你不回我消息
Shure's GF: He said you don't reply to my messages.
Shure的女友: 然后我又要把你删掉了
Shure's GF: So I need to delete you.
Shure的女友: 干嘛要举报
Shure's GF: Why do you want to report?
Shure的女友: 说谎是吧
Shure's GF: Are you lying?
Shure:  那确实这一茬一个准
Shure: Well, it's true, it happens every time.
Shure的女友: 什么叫这一茬一个准
Shure's GF: What do you mean "every time"?
Shure的女友: 嘿你要干嘛
Shure's GF: Hey, what are you doing?
Shure:  呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure:  加入黑名单
Shure: Adding to the blacklist.
Shure:  请你饶了我最后一命吧
Shure: Please, spare me one last time.
Shure:  尊严
Shure: Dignity.
Shure:  那研究一下去杭州的票怎么买吧
Shure: Let's look into how to buy tickets to Hangzhou.
Shure的女友: 先上海到杭州
Shure's GF: First from Shanghai to Hangzhou.
Shure的女友: 明天好像五一开票
Shure's GF: Seems like tickets for May 1st go on sale tomorrow.
Shure:  今天开
Shure: They go on sale today.
Shure的女友：明
Shure's GF: Tomorrow.
Shure:  但是我看了票很足
Shure: But I checked, there are plenty of tickets.
Shure的女友: 哪到哪票很足
Shure's GF: Plenty of tickets from where to where?
Shure的女友: 从北京
Shure's GF: From Beijing.
Shure: 上海到杭州的票很足
Shure: Plenty of tickets from Shanghai to Hangzhou.
Shure的女友: 没有我说明天开五一的票啊
Shure's GF: No, I mean tickets for May 1st go on sale tomorrow.
Shure:  你说回来的票是吧
Shure: You're talking about the return tickets, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  回来的话我搜一下啊
Shure: I'll check the return tickets.
Shure的女友: 杭州
Shure's GF: Hangzhou.
Shure的女友: 北京什么常州啊
Shure's GF: Beijing, what about Changzhou?
Shure的女友: 北京
Shure's GF: Beijing.
Shure:  啊这不也也也
Shure: Ah, this is also...
Shure的女友: 这是29
Shure's GF: This is 29.
Shure的女友: 这是30五一明天开票
Shure's GF: This is 30. Tickets for May 1st go on sale tomorrow.
Shure:  那一样一样一样
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure:  差不多只有这一版
Shure: It's almost only this version.
Shure:  12个小时
Shure: 12 hours.
Shure:  也行
Shure: That works.
Shure的女友：所以为什么要闯出来
Shure's GF: So why break through?
Shure:  那不然呢
Shure: What else?
Shure:  回北京啊
Shure: Go back to Beijing.
Shure:  咦
Shure: Hmm?
Shure的女友: 为什么啊这是
Shure's GF: Why is that?
Shure的女友: 定死了
Shure's GF: It's fixed.
Shure的女友: 这是我非非回不可了
Shure's GF: I have to go back.
Shure的女友: 啊是这样吗
Shure's GF: Is that so?
Shure的女友：好的谢谢
Shure's GF: Okay, thank you.
Shure:  好的谢谢
Shure: Okay, thank you.
Shure:  窦总给你
Shure: Here you go, Dou.
Shure的女友: 我有几只手
Shure's GF: How many hands do I have?
Shure:  呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe.
Shure的女友我有几只手
Shure's GF: How many hands do I have?
Shure的女友: 我有三根筷子
Shure's GF: I have three chopsticks.
Shure:  这个AI提出了个问题
Shure: This AI raised a question.
Shure:  为什么我给了他三只筷子
Shure: Why did I give him three chopsticks?
Shure:  这三只寓意着什么
Shure: What do these three chopsticks symbolize?
Shure:  犯错了
Shure: Made a mistake.
Shure的女友: 哎回北京机票只要
Shure's GF: Hey, a flight to Beijing only costs...
Shure的女友: 哎呦
Shure's GF: Oh no.
Shure:  差不多差不多
Shure: Almost, almost.
Shure的女友: 这是2号
Shure's GF: This is the 2nd.
Shure:  经停一下
Shure: A short stop.
Shure的女友: 这是2号
Shure's GF: This is the 2nd.
Shure的女友: 他在哪在日照经停
Shure's GF: Where's the stopover?
Shure的女友: 你在日照经停
Shure's GF: You stop over at Rizhao.
Shure的女友: 你还回什么长春啊
Shure's GF: Why go back to Changchun then?
Shure:  日照是哪
Shure: Where's Rizhao?
Shure的女友: 日照在山东
Shure's GF: Rizhao is in Shandong.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure:  哦我想起来了
Shure: Oh, I remember now.
Shure:  那个翻拍的真人版海贼王就
Shure: That live-action remake of One Piece...
Shure:  在日照知道吗
Shure: was filmed in Rizhao, you know?
Shure:  呵呵你不知道吗
Shure: Haha, don't you know?
Shure:  我朝拜那个词就在这学的
Shure: I learned the word "worship" here.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友: 什么军运版海贼王啊
Violet: What is this military version of One Piece?
Shure的女友: 什么东西啊
Violet: What is that?
Shure:  我他妈给你找一下
Shure: Let me find it for you.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey
Shure的女友: 我应该
Violet: I should
Shure的女友: 25号很忙26号跟朋友喝酒
Violet: I'm busy on the 25th, and drinking with friends on the 26th.
Shure的女友: 27号没定
Violet: The 27th is not planned yet.
Shure:  Disney
Shure: Disney
Shure的女友: 但你26号才到啊
Violet: But you're only arriving on the 26th.
Shure的女友: 咱俩真的要一起玩吗
Violet: Are we really going to hang out together?
Shure:  怎么上海的朋友不方便见
Shure: Is it inconvenient to meet friends in Shanghai?
Shure:  还是说上海有个小
Shure: Or is there a...
Shure:  养个小的是吗
Shure: Are you keeping someone in Shanghai?
Shure的女友: 不是什么
Violet: No, it's not that.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Oh
Shure的女友:什么这不是怕你去
Violet: It's just, I'm afraid you'll go and...
Shure的女友: 你有你有
Violet: You have...
Shure的女友: 你自己要忙什么
Violet: You have your own stuff to do.
Shure:  我有什么要忙的
Shure: What do I have to do?
Shure的女友: 对周一哎
Violet: Right, Monday, um...
Shure的女友: 你不要长春
Violet: Don't you have to go to Changchun?
Shure:  你别动我先查一会儿
Shure: Don't move, let me check it first.
Shure:  我想回一趟啊
Shure: I want to go back once.
Shure的女友: 你想回趟
Violet: You want to go back?
Shure的女友: 嗯好那你回
Violet: Well, then go back.
Shure:  哇杭州飞回去居然要这么贵
Shure: Wow, flying back from Hangzhou is so expensive.
Shure:  行吧
Shure: Fine then.
Shure的女友:高铁也定价
Violet: The high-speed train is also expensive.
Shure: 也是
Shure: True.
Shure的女友: 你五一坐飞机不如坐高铁
Violet: You'd be better off taking the high-speed train than flying on May Day.
Shure:  为什么
Shure: Why?
Shure的女友: 19个小时北京转
Violet: It's 19 hours with a transfer in Beijing.
Shure的女友: 你还不如高铁呢
Violet: You'd be better off taking the high-speed train.
Shure:  北京给你扔回去
Shure: Beijing is just going to throw you back.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友：哎，好呀
Violet: Yeah, okay.
Shure的女友：你还不如高铁呢
Violet: You'd be better off taking the high-speed train.
Shure:  有道理
Shure: Makes sense.
Shure:  还有这趟
Shure: And this trip...
Shure:  你那三天攻略吗
Shure: Is it your three-day plan?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Shure:  那么29号到
Shure: So, arriving on the 29th.
Shure的女友：29 30 1号
Shure: 29, 30, and the 1st.
Shure:  1号8天你
Shure: Eight days starting from the 1st?
Shure的女友： 不不不不不不不不不no no no no no不是
Shure: No no no no no no, no, that's not it.
Shure:  收藏了我收藏了我收藏了我收藏了
Shure: I saved it, I saved it, I saved it.
Shure的女友: 你看这是三天
Shure: Look, this is the three-day plan.
Shure的女友: 第一天什么什么什么什么寺
Shure: First day, some temple...
Shure的女友: 什么什么博物馆
Shure: Some museum...
Shure的女友: 你会去吗你不会
Shure: Will you go? No, you won't.
Shure:  我的妈
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure的女友: 然后第二天就是西湖边上转一圈
Shure: Then on the second day, a walk around West Lake.
Shure的女友: 这个可以有
Shure: That could work.
Shure的女友: 然后第三天看日出
Shure: Then on the third day, watching the sunrise.
Shure的女友: 大哥看日出
Shure: Bro, watching the sunrise.
Shure:  不能有吗
Shure: Can't we do that?
Shure:  然后两个寺
Shure: And two temples.
Shure的女友: 所以对我来说这杭州能玩得起这一个
Shure: So for me, Hangzhou can be done in one go.
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友: 然后吃吃喝喝
Shure: Then eating and drinking.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Shure的女友: 5月1号走就好了
Shure: Leave on May 1st.
Shure的女友：你非得
Shure: You have to...
Shure的女友: 你5月一号走
Shure: Leave on May 1st.
Shure的女友: 你还可以赶个晚集
Shure: You can still make it for the evening market.
Shure的女友: 给自己过个生日回家
Shure: Celebrate your birthday and then go home.
Shure:  什么玩意啊
Shure: What the heck?
Shure的女友: 不是吗
Shure: Isn't that right?
Shure的女友: 差一天不叫差
Shure: Missing by a day doesn't count.
Shure:  明天就突然收到了12306的信息
Shure: Suddenly tomorrow, you'll get a message from 12306.
Shure:  从杭州到长春的高铁票
Shure: A high-speed train ticket from Hangzhou to Changchun.
Shure的女友: 我能活着回北京吗
Shure: Will I make it back to Beijing alive?
Shure:  能
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure的女友: 笑什么
Shure: What are you laughing at?
Shure:  正好五一过了
Shure: Just after the May Day holiday.
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Shure's GF: Haha
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure's GF: What?
Shure: 正好五一过了我能领证
Shure: Just after May Day, I can get my license.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  怎么了怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's up, what's up, what's up?
Shure:  听歌猴子怎么了
Shure: Listening to music, what's wrong, Monkey?
Shure:  我去要瓶北冰洋
Shure: I'm going to get a bottle of Arctic Ocean.
Shure:  有点太干了
Shure: It's a bit too dry.
Shure:  你要吗
Shure: Do you want one?
Shure:  什么你要喝饮料吗
Shure: What? Do you want a drink?
Shure:  太干了
Shure: It's too dry.
Shure的女友: 我就想要面汤
Shure's GF: I just want some noodle soup.
Shure:  你好那个来瓶北冰洋
Shure: Hi, can I get a bottle of Arctic Ocean?
Shure:  然后有面汤吗
Shure: And do you have noodle soup?
Shure:  来碗面汤
Shure: A bowl of noodle soup.
Shure:  北冰洋要凉的
Shure: The Arctic Ocean should be cold.
Shure: 哎好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure的女友：干嘛
Shure's GF: What are you doing?
Shure: 你尝尝
Shure: Try it.
Shure的女友：一脸疑惑的在那里
Shure's GF: Looking puzzled over there.
Shure的女友：柠檬的
Shure's GF: It's lemon.
Shure的女友：哦，他其实不止有橙子呀
Shure's GF: Oh, it’s not just orange.
Shure: 我的发
Shure: My hair...
Shure的女友：你不知道呀
Shure's GF: Didn't you know?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I didn't know.
Shure: 谢谢您
Shure: Thank you.
Shure:   抢
Shure: Grab it.
Shure:  喝吧你就
Shure: Just drink it.
Shure:  喝不死你
Shure: It won't kill you.
Shure:  这是柠檬味都
Shure: This is all lemon-flavored.
Shure的女友: 是啊不然呢
Shure's GF: Yeah, what else?
Shure:  AI看见了吗
Shure: AI, did you see that?
Shure的女友：你以为他没有位置了
Shure's GF: You thought it didn't have a place?
Shure的女友: 以为他变味道了
Shure's GF: Thought it changed its flavor?
Shure:  对我以为我味觉这两天失灵了
Shure: Yeah, I thought my taste buds were off these days.
Shure的女友：没有，他确实味道不一样
Shure's GF: No, it really tastes different.
Shure:  柠檬味的北冰洋
Shure: Lemon-flavored Arctic Ocean.
Shure:  滚出北京
Shure: Get out of Beijing.
Shure的女友: 什么东西凭什么滚出北京
Shure's GF: What do you mean, get out of Beijing?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure的女友: 这个不是不好喝哪
Shure's GF: This isn't bad to drink.
Shure: 他拿
Shure: He took it.
Shure:  哎嘘
Shure: Hey, shh.
Shure的女友: 其实我感觉
Shure's GF: Actually, I feel...
Shure的女友: 这个比那个橙子那个要好喝一点
Shure's GF: This one tastes better than the orange one.
Shure的女友: 因为它它的酸度和甜度中和的特别好
Shure's GF: Because its acidity and sweetness are balanced really well.
Shure的女友: 然后那个就只有甜味和起泡
Shure's GF: The other one is just sweet and fizzy.
Shure的女友: 你不要抖腿
Shure's GF: Stop shaking your leg.
Shure:  让老北京听着能拿刀砍你
Shure: An old Beijinger would be ready to cut you with a knife.
Shure的女友：为什么
Shure's GF: Why?
Shure:  这跟那个柠檬味的可乐有什么区别
Shure: How is this different from lemon-flavored cola?
Shure的女友：但雪碧就是柠檬味的呀
Shure's GF: But Sprite is lemon-flavored.
Shure: 挠死你
Shure: I'll tickle you to death.
Shure的女友: 那根谋杀
Shure's GF: That's attempted murder.
Shure:  淹死我
Shure: Drown me.
Shure的女友: 我不是要两根吗
Shure's GF: Didn't I ask for two?
Shure的女友: 为什么只有一根呢
Shure's GF: Why is there only one?
Shure:  因为
Shure: Because...
Shure:  AI刚才捕捉下来了
Shure: The AI just captured it.
Shure:  那根蹦下去了
Shure: That one bounced away.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure:  你看你就提出了一个很好的问题
Shure: See, you just raised a good question.
Shure:  没有这谢彬竹告诉我的这个
Shure: Without Xie Binzhu telling me this...
Shure:  这个数据集到底要干什么
Shure: What exactly is this dataset for?
Shure的女友: 干什么
Shure's GF: For what?
Shure:  需要我们提为什么
Shure: We need to ask why.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  大概他就是能预测一下你要干什么
Shure: Basically, it can predict what you want to do.
Shure:  你你肯定不懂我在说什么
Shure: You probably don't understand what I'm saying.
Shure:  因为你的理解能力有问题
Shure: Because your comprehension skills are lacking.
Shure的女友: 你猜我现在要干什么
Shure's GF: Guess what I'm going to do now.
Shure:  你在骂我傻逼
Shure: You're cursing at me.
Shure的女友: 我要捶你一拳
Shure's GF: I'm going to punch you.
Shure:  好你看人家能不能预测到
Shure: Okay, see if it can predict when you'll punch me.
Shure:  你什么时候捶我
Shure: When you'll punch me.
Shure:  你在我筷子伸进嘴里的那一刻
Shure: Right when I put my chopsticks in my mouth.
Shure:  然后捶我一下我靠
Shure: Then you'll punch me. Damn.
Shure的女友：给我张纸
Shure's GF: Give me a tissue.
Shure的女友: 一张
Shure's GF: Just one.
Shure:  你看这就笑的流口水了
Shure: Look, you're drooling from laughing.
Shure:  看到了吗AI
Shure: Did you see that AI?
Shure:  哎哎哈哈哈好
Shure: Haha, okay.
Shure:  好像我们俩之间一直隔了一个Steve一样
Shure: It's like there's always a Steve between us.
Shure:  好了
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  你今天的名字就叫Steve了好吗
Shure: Your name is Steve today, okay?
Shure:  哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure:  哈哈哈你要干什么
Shure: Hahaha, what are you doing?
Shure的女友: 我们的谢彬竹能不能给你收回来
Shure's GF: Can you take our Xie Binzhu back?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  你要干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure:  人类就喜欢把别人当做自己配的一环
Shure: Humans like to treat others as a part of their own setup.
Shure:  谢冰竹也是我们的Pad一环嗯
Shure: Xie Binzhu is also a part of our setup, right?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Shure:  吃饭吃饭吃饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Shure: 我想把这个倒出给你一份
Shure: I want to pour some of this out for you.
Shure:  他们在学高数啊
Shure: They're studying advanced math?
Shure:  背角公式
Shure: The cosine formula.
Shure:  绊角公式
Shure: The sine formula.
Shure:  不对啊他在考教资啊
Shure: No, wait, they're taking the teaching qualification exam.
Shure的女友: 啊 教资啊
Shure's GF: Ah, teaching qualification exam.
Shure:  背角公式
Shure: The cosine formula.
Shure:  半角公式
Shure: The sine formula.
Shure:  啥时候学来着
Shure: When did we learn that?
Shure:  是高数吗
Shure: Was it advanced math?
Shure的女友: 嗯其他人
Shure's GF: Hmm, other people.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  这谁啊
Shure: Who is this?
Shure的女友：另一个抽像哥
Shure's GF: Another abstract guy.
Shure的女友: 他考研啊
Shure's GF: He's preparing for postgraduate exams.
Shure的女友: 他连那个大学物理都能连连挂4年
Shure's GF: He failed university physics for four consecutive years.
Shure的女友: 他考研
Shure's GF: And he's preparing for postgraduate exams.
Shure的女友: 是啊他大一上的课到现在他都没过
Shure's GF: Yeah, he hasn't passed his freshman year courses yet.
Shure的女友: 可不就是连挂四年
Shure's GF: Of course, he failed for four years.
Shure的女友: 笑什么
Shure's GF: What's so funny?
Shure: 这是正常人类吗
Shure: Is he even a normal human?
Shure的女友：给我拿个勺可以吗？
Shure's GF: Can you get me a spoon?
Shure:  好的对不起
Shure: Okay, sorry.
Shure:  是我没眼力见了我自责
Shure: It's my fault, I blame myself.
Shure的女友：是的
Shure's GF: Yes.
Shure:  你好那个拿个勺
Shure: Hi, can you get a spoon?
Shure:  勺
Shure: Spoon.
Shure: 脚为什么
Shure: Why the foot?
Shure的女友：突然想起来，吃凉皮怎么能不放醋呢
Shure's GF: Suddenly remembered, how can you eat cold noodles without vinegar?
Shure的女友：哦，I'm sorry.
Shure's GF: Oh, I'm sorry.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  看到了吗
Shure: Did you see that?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure的女友：闭嘴
Shure's GF: Shut up.
Shure: 我不解释AI应该也能看到这
Shure: I don't explain, AI should be able to see this.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure的女友:好烦啊
Shure's GF: So annoying.
Shure的女友: 我真讨厌你
Shure's GF: I really hate you.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 干嘛
Shure: What?
Shure的女友: 往下拽拽
Shure's GF: Pull it down.
Shure的女友: 你这个一直挂在上面
Shure's GF: This has been hanging there the whole time.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  吃岔气了
Shure: Ate too fast.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure:  太饿了哥
Shure: I'm so hungry, bro.
Shure:  会好一点吗
Shure: Does it feel a bit better?
Shure的女友: 不会但是能让他少一点
Shure's GF: No, but it makes it less.
Shure:  显显你没有那么浪费是吗
Shure: Show that you are not that wasteful, right?
Shure:  你怎么笑的这么开心
Shure: Why are you smiling so happily?
Shure:  是不是突然快乐了今天
Shure: Are you suddenly happy today?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  你看看这就是嘴硬
Shure: Look, this is being stubborn.
Shure:  看到了吗
Shure: See that?
Shure:  哎AI
Shure: Hey AI.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure的女友: 谢明珠几点回来
Shure's GF: When is Xie Mingzhu coming back?
Shure的女友: 我要去告状
Shure's GF: I want to complain.
Shure:  谢明珠一直都在
Shure: Xie Mingzhu is always here.
Shure:  那什么啊
Shure: What's that?
Shure:  谢明珠一直都在
Shure: Xie Mingzhu is always here.
Shure的女友: 她昨天晚上不是回来了吗
Shure's GF: Didn't she come back last night?
Shure:  对我一直都在学校
Shure: Yeah, I was at school the whole time.
Shure的女友: 她一直都在学校
Shure's GF: She was at school the whole time.
Shure的女友: 嗯我要去告状
Shure's GF: Hmm, I'm going to report this.
Shure的女友: 太可怕了
Shure's GF: This is too scary.
Shure的女友：昨天晚上一点看朋友圈
Shure's GF: I was checking my moments at 1 AM last night.
Shure的女友: 就看见他发
Shure's GF: And I saw his post.
Shure的女友: 他跟他男朋友打视频的电话
Shure's GF: He was video calling with his boyfriend.
Shure的女友: 给我撞死了
Shure's GF: I almost died from shock.
Shure的女友: 谁想一点看我四张脸
Shure's GF: Who wants to see four faces at 1 AM?
Shure:  为什么四张脸
Shure: Why four faces?
Shure:  还有他爸妈
Shure: Were his parents there too?
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  因为他发了四张截图啊嗯
Shure: Because he posted four screenshots.
Shure: 啊，嗯
Shure: Ah, yeah.
Shure:  咱俩咋咱不羡慕
Shure: Why aren't we envious?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure的女友: 我真的是有点想跟你竖中指
Shure's GF: I kind of want to flip you off.
Shure:  呵呵呵不要
Shure: Haha, don't do that.
Shure:  AI没有这个
Shure: AI can't do that.
Shure:  他没有中指
Shure: It doesn't have a middle finger.
Shure的女友: 不是就是我在那躺着准备睡觉了
Shure's GF: No, I was lying there getting ready to sleep.
Shure的女友: 然后刷一眼朋友圈
Shure's GF: Then I scrolled through my moments.
Shure的女友: 然后点开第一条
Shure's GF: And clicked on the first one.
Shure的女友: 习惯性的点开了那个图片
Shure's GF: I habitually clicked on the picture.
Shure的女友: 然后就跟他女朋友照片四目相对
Shure's GF: And then I made eye contact with his girlfriend's photo.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈
Shure's GF: Hahaha.
Shure:  居然捞上来了
Shure: He actually fished it up.
Shure:  太神奇了
Shure: That's amazing.
Shure的女友: 山西过油肉和北京过油肉有啥区别
Shure's GF: What's the difference between Shanxi fried meat and Beijing fried meat?
Shure:  哪有北京过油肉
Shure: There's no Beijing fried meat.
Shure的女友: 没有啊
Shure's GF: Really?
Shure的女友: 只是突然想到了而已
Shure's GF: I just thought of it suddenly.
Shure:  北京有过油肉吗
Shure: Does Beijing have fried meat?
Shure的女友: 有吧我吃到过
Shure's GF: I think so, I've had it.
Shure:  那你知道是老北京
Shure: Then you must know it's Old Beijing.
Shure:  山西过油肉
Shure: Shanxi fried meat.
Shure的女友: 好吧
Shure's GF: Alright.
Shure:  我也没吃过过油肉是
Shure: I've never had fried meat.
Shure: 这是啥啊
Shure: What is this?
Shure的女友：安口的群
Sister: Ankou's group
Shure: 他说什么呢
Shure: What did he say?
Shure:  又在拍一个我
Shure: Filming me again
Shure: 那再拍一个我
Shure: Then film me again
Shure:  哎这为什么是录视频
Shure: Hey, why is it recording a video?
Shure:  哎这个人类为什么点了
Shure: Hey, why did this person start recording a video after taking a photo?
Shure:  点了拍照之后然后开始录视频
Shure: Why, why?
Shure:  为什么为什么
Shure: Okay, okay
Shure:  可以了可以了
Shure: You can stop now
Shure:  可以停了
Shure: You can stop
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure:  多可爱
Shure: So cute
Shure:  跟你的眼镜过去嘛哈哈哈
Shure: Go with your glasses, hahaha
Shure的女友：他问你什么时候回
Sister: He asked when you'll be back
Shure的女友：你俩聊吧
Sister: You two chat
Shure:  我明天答辩完应该中午左右回去吧
Shure: I'll probably come back around noon after my defense tomorrow
Shure:  就是中午左右能到
Shure: Should be around noon
Shure:  先给他画个饼
Shure: Let's give him a heads-up first
Shure:  那可以啊可以啊
Shure: That's fine, that's fine
Shure:  那正好你再帮我拿点东西
Shure: Then you can help me bring some stuff
Shure:  他们那边缺点东西
Shure: They're missing some stuff over there
Shure:  我给拿点
Shure: I'll bring some
Shure:  我的咖啡首充套装
Shure: My coffee starter pack
Shure:  以及一个音箱
Shure: And a speaker
Shure的女友: 为什么缺音箱啊
Sister: Why do they need a speaker?
Shure:  因为觉得那个大厅不放点东西
Shure: Because it feels like a waste not to have one in the hall
Shure:  真的可惜了
Shure: Really a shame
Shure:  或者每每天在那个院子里面坐着
Shure: Or sitting in the yard every day
Shure:  晒太阳时
Shure: When sunbathing
Shure:  不放点东西真的可惜了
Shure: It's really a shame not to have one
Shure:  我靠老他妈惬意了
Shure: Damn, it's so cozy
Shure:  来吧来吧来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on, come on
Shure:  明天答完辩
Shure: After my defense tomorrow
Shure:  直接跟我一起去吧
Shure: Just come with me
Shure的女友：干嘛
Sister: Why?
Shure:  当我的抱枕
Shure: Be my pillow
Shure: : 哈哈哈哈对不起
Shure: Hahahaha, sorry
Shure:  合理吧
Shure: Makes sense, right?
Shure: 我晚上睡不着觉然后带了个抱枕
Shure: I can't sleep at night, so I brought a pillow
Shure的女友: 你晚上真睡不着觉吗
Sister: Can you really not sleep at night?
Shure的女友: 我就问啊
Shure: I'm just asking.
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 是不是昨天晚上比你睡得晚
Shure: Did you go to bed later than me last night?
Shure的女友: 你睡眠质量多好
Shure: You sleep so well.
Shure的女友: 你睡不着觉
Shure: You can't fall asleep?
Shure:  睡不着我昨天晚上你看比你睡得晚
Shure: I couldn't sleep either. You see, I went to bed later than you last night.
Shure:  一点半多睡的
Shure: I slept at around 1:30.
Shure:  早上7点就醒了
Shure: Woke up at 7 in the morning.
Shure的女友: 你要不要看我几点醒
Shure: Do you want to know what time I woke up?
Shure:  那我说我的抱枕睡眠质量不好
Shure: I think my body pillow's sleep quality isn't good.
Shure的女友: 哎呀你好讨厌啊
Shure: Oh, you're so annoying.
Shure的女友: 这样我可以明天下午陪你过去看球
Shure: This way, I can accompany you to watch the game tomorrow afternoon.
Shure的女友: 如果你到坐地铁的话
Shure: If you take the subway.
Shure:  我们打车公费
Shure: We can take a cab on the company's dime.
Shure:  你不蹭一下吗
Shure: Don't you want to join us?
Shure的女友: 你们离环球多远
Shure: How far are you from Universal?
Shure:  我们应该很近
Shure: We should be very close.
Shure:  我给你搜那个地方
Shure: I'll look up that place for you.
Shure的女友: 你用你自己手机啊
Shure: Use your own phone.
Shure:  昂，对我操
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure:  我忘了我有手机了
Shure: I forgot I have my phone.
Shure的女友: 你输半天没输对你
Shure: You've been typing for ages and still got it wrong.
Shure: 肯定很近
Shure: It's definitely very close.
Shure:  哪个地方
Shure: Which place?
Shure的女友: 环球
Shure: Universal.
Shure的女友: 你直接点这个就好了
Shure: Just click on this.
Shure:  看加车的是
Shure: Look, add the car.
Shure的女友:8公里呢
Shure: 8 kilometers.
Shure:  那不也很近了吗
Shure: Isn't that close enough?
Shure:  公交
Shure: By bus.
Shure的女友：一号线
Shure: Line 1.
Shure的女友: 1号线一站
Shure: One stop on Line 1.
Shure:  就是这远了一点
Shure: That's a bit far.
Shure:  我们可以途经给你设一个下车点
Shure: We can set a drop-off point for you along the way.
Shure:  然后让你在花庄下
Shure: And then you get off at Huazhuang.
Shure:  然后坐到环球
Shure: And then head to Universal.
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Shure:  去你的后花园吧
Shure: Go to your backyard.
Shure的女友: 看我明天空不空吧
Shure: Let's see if I'm free tomorrow.
Shure的女友: 我要空我就溜一圈
Shure: If I'm free, I'll take a stroll.
Shure:  想我就来看看我哟
Shure: If you miss me, just come and see me.
Shure的女友：不想
Shure's GF: I don't miss you.
Shure:  咦死鸭子嘴
Shure: Oh, you're just being stubborn.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 太恶心了
Shure: So gross.
Shure:  对不起数据集
Shure: Sorry about that, data set.
Shure:  请你忘掉这段
Shure: Please forget that part.
Shure的女友: 你饭搭子没说完他问你要拿啥
Shure's GF: Your lunch buddy didn't finish, he asked what you were going to take.
Shure:  明天明天
Shure: Tomorrow, tomorrow.
Shure:  一会晚上回宿舍跟你说
Shure: I'll tell you tonight when we get back to the dorm.
Shure:  没有咖啡豆了
Shure: We're out of coffee beans.
Shure:  只剩你那最后一袋了
Shure: Only your last bag is left.
Shure的女友: 点我呢
Shure's GF: Are you talking to me?
Shure:  没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  没有
Shure: No.
Shure:  没有这次正好公费买俩袋
Shure: No, this time we just bought two bags with public funds.
Shure:  给大家磨着喝
Shure: We'll grind it for everyone to drink.
Shure的女友：嗯，居家小能手
Shure's GF: Hmm, you're such a homemaker.
Shure:  你可以来
Shure: You can come.
Shure:  你把那那袋豆子喝完再走
Shure: You can finish that bag of beans before you leave.
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure's GF: What?
Shure:  你来
Shure: Come.
Shure:  你把那袋豆子喝完再走
Shure: Finish that bag of beans before you leave.
Shure:  你说你来
Shure: You said you'd come.
Shure:  喝我的咖啡
Shure: To drink my coffee.
Shure的女友: 跟带孩子似的
Shure's GF: It's like taking care of a child.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right.
Shure的女友: 啊我们那天
Shure's GF: Ah, that day...
Shure的女友: 那天在跳海不是碰见陆哥了吗
Shure's GF: That day when we were jumping into the sea, didn't we run into Brother Lu?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure的女友: 然后然后他说你怎么这个点在这
Shure's GF: And then he asked why I was there at that time.
Shure的女友: 我说啊我等修硕我排练
Shure's GF: I said, oh, I'm waiting for Shure, I'm rehearsing.
Shure的女友: 然后然后就
Shure's GF: And then we...
Shure的女友: 在聊我说对他两个小时
Shure's GF: We were talking and I said, yeah, two hours.
Shure的女友: 你看课外班也是两个小时
Shure's GF: You see, after-school classes are also two hours.
Shure: : 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友: 我就在接孩子放学
Shure's GF: I was just picking up a kid from school.
Shure:  确实很像
Shure: It's really similar.
Shure:  饱了
Shure: I'm full.
Shure:  那个
Shure: That...
Shure:  叫什么来着啊
Shure: What was it called again?
Shure:  王一哲每次来都点这个
Shure: Wang Yizhe orders this every time he comes.
Shure:  然后配配两个肉夹馍
Shure: And then he gets two meat sandwiches.
Shure的女友：配什么
Shure's GF: With what?
Shure:  配两个肉夹馍
Shure: With two meat sandwiches.
Shure:  他说这个很很正宗
Shure: He says it's really authentic.
Shure:  跟他那边的很像
Shure: Just like the ones from his place.
Shure的女友: 我那天不是跟你说今天
Shure's GF: Didn't I tell you that day, today
Shure的女友: 那天去中关村
Shure's GF: That day we went to Zhongguancun
Shure的女友: 那天不是跟你说想吃凉皮吗
Shure's GF: Didn't I tell you I wanted to eat cold noodles?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure的女友:跟你说了吧
Shure's GF: I told you, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah
Shure:  吃上了嗯
Shure: Did you get to eat them, hmm?
Shure的女友: 好好
Shure's GF: Okay, good
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Shure:  教练明天出现在我出去的吉利物数字
Shure: The coach will appear tomorrow with my lucky number.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure的女友: 哈哈太坏了
Shure's GF: Haha, that's too mean.
Shure的女友: 换掉
Shure's GF: Change it.
Shure:  好我明天换
Shure: Okay, I'll change it tomorrow.
Shure:  明天换
Shure: Change it tomorrow.
Shure的女友: 你今天换
Shure's GF: Change it today.
Shure的女友: 你现在换
Shure's GF: Change it now.
Shure:  不我每次录像的时候换掉好吧
Shure: No, I'll change it every time we record, okay?
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure:  喝完凉的喝热的
Shure: Drink something hot after something cold.
Shure:  不对喝完热的喝凉的
Shure: No, drink something cold after something hot.
Shure:  胃要不要了
Shure: Do you want to ruin your stomach?
Shure的女友: 不要了
Shure's GF: Don't need it.
Shure:  给我吧
Shure: Give it to me.
Shure的女友:给你了
Shure's GF: Here you go.
Shure:  拿出来吧
Shure: Take it out.
Shure:  求你让我最后一面
Shure: Please, let me see you one last time.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure:  咳咳
Shure: Cough cough
Shure的女友:怎么了
Shure's GF: What's wrong?
Shure:  我又想起了一个今天新看到的梗
Shure: I just remembered a new joke I saw today.
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure's GF: What?
Shure:  这这不能播
Shure: This, this can't be broadcast.
Shure:  等会再告诉你
Shure: I'll tell you later.
Shure的女友: 不能播是什么呀
Shure's GF: What can't be broadcast?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure's GF: What?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  没事没事
Shure: It's nothing, it's nothing.
Shure的女友:你一会你忘了
Shure's GF: You'll forget later.
Shure:  我不能忘
Shure: I won't forget.
Shure的女友: 你忘
Shure's GF: You'll forget.
Shure: 啊我现在给你讲
Shure: I'll tell you now.
Shure的女友: 嗯
Shure's GF: Hmm.
Shure:  你知道为什么要摸你屁股吗
Shure: Do you know why he touched your butt?
Shure:  因为他太沉了
Shure: Because it's too heavy.
Shure:  我帮你拖着
Shure: I was helping you carry it.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure:  忘掉忘掉忘掉忘掉
Shure: Forget it, forget it, forget it.
Shure:  这种烂梗不要记得
Shure: Don't remember such a bad joke.
Shure的女友:我给你扔出去
Shure's GF: I'll throw you out.
Shure的女友: 我哈哈神经病啊
Shure's GF: Haha, you're crazy.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 咦
Shure's GF: Ew.
Shure: 咦什么咦
Shure: Ew what?
Shure的女友什么:东西啊
Shure's GF: What is that?
Shure:  对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's wrong?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  呵呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure:  干什么什么表情
Shure: What kind of expression is that?
Shure的女友: 呵呵为什么这句话变得莫名其妙的
Shure's GF: Why did that sentence become so weird?
Shure:  我可能那个节奏没有掌握对
Shure: Maybe I didn't get the rhythm right.
Shure的女友: 什么叫哪个哪个节奏
Shure's GF: What do you mean by rhythm?
Shure的女友: 什么节奏
Shure's GF: What rhythm?
Shure:  就是抖这个包袱的节奏没掌握对
Shure: I didn't get the timing of the punchline right.
Shure的女友: 什么包袱
Shure's GF: What punchline?
Shure:  就刚刚那个那个那个那个那个
Shure: Just now, the, the, the...
Shure:  举举着的那个
Shure: The one I was holding onto.
Shure的女友: 什么
Shure's GF: What?
Shure:  就刚刚那个摸屁股的那个包袱
Shure: The punchline about touching your butt.
Shure的女友：啊
Shure's GF: Ah.
Shure的女友: 走北门走东门
Shure's GF: Let's go to the north gate, then the east gate.
Shure: 走北门把
Shure: Let's go through the north gate.
Shure:  哦我们要去那哪
Shure: Oh, where are we going?
Shure:  但是一样吧
Shure: But it's the same, right?
Shure的女友：其实差不多
Shure's GF: Actually, it's pretty much the same.
Shure:  嗯对差不多
Shure: Yeah, pretty much.
Shure:  哎哟吃岔气了
Shure: Oh no, I got indigestion.
Shure:  哔哔哔哔哔哔哔哔哔哔
Shure: Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep.
Shure:  这个眼镜的价值比我命都值钱
Shure: These glasses are worth more than my life.
Shure:  猜猜他多少钱
Shure: Guess how much they cost.
Shure的女友: 不是我是在想谢彬竹怎么莫名其妙的
Shure's GF: No, I was just wondering why Xie Binzhu was acting so weird.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:这是我呀
Shure's GF: That's me!
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友: 哈哈哈哈
Shure's GF: Hahahaha.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure:  OK神经病
Shure: Okay, you weirdo.
Shure的女友: 你好吵哦
Shure's GF: You're so noisy.
Shure:  你看我不吵你还想我
Shure: See, if I'm not noisy, you'll miss me.
Shure:  我不想你
Shure: I don't miss you.
Shure:  死鸭子嘴硬
Shure: Stubborn as a mule.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友：什么呀
Shure's GF: What?
Shure的女友: 吵死了
Shure's GF: So annoying.
Shure的女友: 啊呜救命
Shure's GF: Ah, help!
Shure:  嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe.
Shure的女友：救命
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure:  你跑我追
Shure: You run, I chase.
Shure:  你插翅难飞
Shure: You can't escape.
Shure的女友: 救命啊
Shure's GF: Help!
Shure的女友: 堵的要死
Shure's GF: I'm so blocked.
Shure:  不是笑的也很开心是吧
Shure: But you're laughing happily, aren't you?
Shure:  给大家看看你是不是笑的很开心
Shure: Show everyone how happy you are.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure的女友: 好烦啊
Shure's GF: So annoying.
Shure的女友: 小狗
Shure's GF: Little dog.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  你为什么还买带小狗的衣服
Shure: Why did you buy clothes with a little dog on them?
Shure的女友: 为什么不可以
Shure's GF: Why can't I?
Shure:  你不是都已经有一只了吗
Shure: Don't you already have a dog?
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈对不起对不起
Shure: Hahahahahahaha, sorry, sorry.
Shure:  你看看
Shure: Look at this.
Shure:  给你看看人类最最幸福最灿烂的笑容
Shure: Let me show you the happiest and brightest smile of humanity.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友：有病
Shure's GF: You're crazy.
Shure:  多好
Shure: So nice.
Shure的女友:确实
Shure's GF: True.
Shure的女友: 家里确实是有
Shure's GF: There really is one at home.
Shure:  那你家外面就没有了吗
Shure: So there's none outside your house?
Shure:  家外面有个娃是吧
Shure: There's a kid outside, right?
Shure的女友: 俩呢
Shure's GF: Two actually.
Shure:  俩细说俩
Shure: Two, really two.
Shure的女友: 哦不对哎
Shure's GF: Oh no, wait.
Shure的女友：我的人设是什么东西来
Shure's GF: What's my character setting again?
Shure:  离婚离异带俩娃
Shure: Divorced with two kids.
Shure的女友 :哦那是俩
Shure's GF: Oh, that's right, two.
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Shure's GF: Haha
Shure:  什么时候让让他们见见我这个新爹啊
Shure: When will you let them meet their new dad?
Shure的女友: 哈哈你有病啊
Shure's GF: Haha, you're crazy.
Shure: 咳
Shure: *cough*
Shure:  没事的我很开放
Shure: It's fine, I'm very open-minded.
Shure:  就当自己孩子养着呗
Shure: I'll just treat them like my own kids.
Shure的女友: 我前几天买了个杯子
Shure's GF: I bought a cup a few days ago.
Shure:  什么杯子
Shure: What kind of cup?
Shure的女友: 就是一个杯子
Shure's GF: Just a cup.
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure的女友：然后是一个玻璃杯
Shure's GF: It was a glass cup.
Shure的女友: 它那个杯子的底座有一点小气泡
Shure's GF: The base of the cup had a small bubble.
Shure的女友: 我去问那个商家我说能不能换一下
Shure's GF: I asked the seller if I could exchange it.
Shure的女友: 因为它底下有有那个气泡
Shure's GF: Because it had a bubble at the bottom.
Shure的女友: 而且杯子确实对于一个杯子来说
Shure's GF: And for a cup, it was really cheap.
Shure的女友: 确实太便宜了
Shure's GF: Really too cheap.
Shure的女友: 然后我觉得
Shure's GF: So I thought,
Shure的女友: 如果我花这个钱拿到那个杯子的话
Shure's GF: If I spent money on this cup,
Shure的女友: 我可能会一直觉得
Shure's GF: I might always feel
Shure的女友: 不太满意我要去问他说好的
Shure's GF: Unsatisfied. So I asked, and they said okay.
Shure的女友: 然后那天我们正好要出门嘛
Shure's GF: Then, we happened to be going out that day.
Shure的女友: 我说那我周一我把这个寄回去吧
Shure's GF: I said I'll send it back on Monday.
Shure的女友: 因为现在准备走了
Shure's GF: Because we were about to leave.
Shure的女友: 就是呃有点来不及了
Shure's GF: So, it was kind of too late.
Shure:  有人在闪我呀
Shure: Someone's distracting me!
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then?
Shure的女友:然后今天就是
Shure's GF: And then today...
Shure的女友: 今天不是腾出空来去寄快递了吗
Shure's GF: Didn't we make some time to send a package today?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure的女友: 我就跟他说
Shure's GF: So I told him...
Shure的女友: 我说哦
Shure's GF: I said, oh...
Shure的女友: 那个你们呃有要求寄哪个物流公司吗
Shure's GF: Do you have a preference for which courier company to use?
Shure的女友: 他跟我说哦
Shure's GF: He told me, oh...
Shure的女友: 那个杯子你自己留着就好了
Shure's GF: You can just keep the cup.
Shure的女友: 我们已经给你补发了
Shure's GF: We've already sent you a replacement.
Shure:  那那个残次品给我吧
Shure: Then give me the defective one.
Shure:  那个残次品是什么哦
Shure: What exactly is the defective one?
Shure:  我们不是回宿舍对
Shure: Aren't we going back to the dorm?
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey...
Shure:  你看看我回来第一眼是来见你
Shure: Look, the first thing I did when I came back was see you.
Shure:  而不是见我的室友
Shure: Not my roommates.
Shure的女友: 你回来第一眼是去吃饭
Shure's GF: The first thing you did was go eat.
Shure:  没有就是来看你
Shure: No, I came to see you.
Shure的女友: 嗯探监
Shure's GF: Oh, visiting a prison.
Shure:  什么探监
Shure: What prison visit?
Shure:  都不知道我在里面待着有多委屈
Shure: You don't know how miserable it was for me in there.
Shure:  回来回来回来回来回来
Shure: Come back, come back, come back, come back.
Shure:  不搞尬的了好吧
Shure: Let's not make it awkward, okay?
Shure的女友: 我跟你讲
Shure's GF: Let me tell you.
Shure的女友: 明天社会新闻就是北邮底下惊现地宫
Shure's GF: Tomorrow's news will be about a hidden underground palace discovered at Beiyou.
Shure的女友: 我连夜挖的
Shure's GF: I dug it overnight.
Shure:  哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Shure:  希望明天可以看到
Shure: Hope to see it tomorrow.
Shure的女友: 哈哈
Shure's GF: Haha.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  我给你多回复一个哈
Shure: I'll give you one more "ha."
Shure的女友: 身体是自己的
Shure's GF: Your body is your own.
Shure的女友: 生气没人替
Shure's GF: No one can be angry for you.